(gentle acoustic guitar music)
- Okay, they said I've
been with my girlfriend
for over a year and I feel
like I'm only staying with her
because I feel like if I leave
she'll kill herself but
there's no more love
in this relationship, just
arguments and problems.
That's a lot.
Ugh, I understand the feeling
of not wanting to be the
reason someone kills themselves
and wanting to save everyone
and I understand depression and sadness
'cause I've been there and I get it
but you can't put it on someone
else like that, you know?
It's just not fair to do.
- My little brother cried
the night I left for college.
That has made me cry more
than I care to admit.
If he watches this, I love you little bro.
I feel like this person
really has a deep connection
with his family.
I wish I had that with my family,
I wish I could tell
him, I could tell my dad
that I love him more.
Yeah, yeah.
- My father has told me
horrible things and abused me
yet he is the only man in my life
that I would do anything for.
Um, wow.
I have been lucky enough
to not go through anything
like this and I think, man,
I think it's a common thing
to both feel love and hatred for people.
It happens a lot more
than we like to believe
and I think, well I would say this person
is just trying to find the happiness
that you look for in him and
other people in your life
within yourself and try to grow from it
as much as you can.
It's hard to realize that your problems
are this big compared to everyone else's.
Sometimes, I know that
everyone has problems,
but people are going
through sh** and that's,
that's hard to cope with sometimes.
- Hm, this is really sad.
I always tell my friends
they have to love themselves
but actually I don't love myself either.
My thoughts is that that
was really authentic,
that was real.
Most of the time we don't
really love ourselves
and if we don't love
ourselves we can't love others
and I think a part of whoever wrote that,
wanting other people to love themselves
because they wanna love themselves
so they tell their friends to do it.
Maybe if their friends could do it
then they could do it but
that's my thoughts on that one.
I feel like I would need to elaborate
because whoever reads that,
they wouldn't understand.
Because it's a complex secret,
it's something that is
built into our society,
there's a lot of societal factors in play
in my secret that people
just don't understand
because they don't deal with it every day,
they don't understand.
- This person wrote I
have yet to be convinced
either by myself or by others
that my life or my passions
have any value whatsoever.
I mean the thing about your passions
is like, at least for me,
that's kind of my reason for living
and kinda vibing on the planet, so.
It also says here that
they're not convinced
that their life has value.
Just know that you're loved
and I had a friend that
didn't think that once
and I wish they would've
come to talk to me.
So yeah.
- I was r**ed and got pregnant, I
wish I never got the abortion.
I mean to be honest, I
kind of had a feeling
that I was going to get one like that,
considering the school that I go to
and the culture that's here,
especially with the Greek life
and the environment that's around that.
I'm sorry that she regrets
having gotten that abortion
and I'm sorry that that happened to her,
it shouldn't happen to
anyone anywhere ever, period.
- I wish I could fake my death
to see how my friends would truly react.
It's a very human feeling,
I feel like everyone thinks about that.
But very real and I hope
they're around friends
who do value their life, yeah.
Um, not really relieved.
I feel like even after writing it
it's gonna stick with me
but the secret is very
dear to me, nonetheless,
even if it's positive or negative,
I feel like I gotta keep it
with me at all times, yeah.
- It's devastating knowing that
I will never be a kid again.
- I'm scared of the question
"You okay?", because I'm not.
- I was once convicted
of first-degree murder.
I don't tell people
because I don't think
they will understand.
- One of my former SVSU professors
would buy alcohol for me
and my underage classmates.
They were also super emotionally abusive
towards us all, lol.
- Last year, I got blackout drunk
and tried to kill myself.
When people ask about the scar on my neck,
I say I got it in a knife fight
with a crazy bitch, which is true
but the crazy bitch was me.
- All my best friends are bad bitches.
I think about kissing them sometimes
but I had a best friend
that I caught feelings for
freshman year and she ghosted me
so I don't want that to happen again.
- I wish people would love
me the way I love them.
- I think I'm trans but I'm too scared
of the implications to actually come out
to anyone other than myself.
You wrote this on campus,
I'll be your friend.
I dunno who you are but just know
I accept you and you're
amazing no matter what
and it can be hard to come out
but it's the right thing to do
and the people who love
you will always accept you
for who you are.
- All right, so this
one says I miss myself.
I dunno where I am.
- It says I miss myself,
I don't know where I am.
I feel like that's
really common in college
'cause we're on a college campus
and it's so heartbreaking because I know
everyone's in the same place
but they're also so distant,
especially with last year, like COVID.
We just had a suicide on this campus too
and it's just so heart wrenching,
it really breaks my heart
to hear stuff like that
'cause that's so sad,
everyone feels alone and lost
so that's sad and I've been there.
- So this person says
I have a lot of friends
but they have other friends
and I only have them
so sometimes I feel alone
when they are distant
with the other friends 'cause
I don't have anybody else.
Huh.
I can relate to that shit,
sadly, but it's fine.
Uh, I feel like I can
low key relate to that,
I'm a pull it back up again.
'Cause yeah, I would say that
I too have a lot of friends
and then I get jealous occasionally
when I feel like they
have other friends too
but it's like, it's
something that I'm personally
really insecure about but it's something
that I feel like I shouldn't
be so I've pushed it back
and it's just kinda like, it's
like a negative feedback loop
of just a bunch of bullshit internally.
- I wish I had more time to enjoy my life.
I feel like a robot sometimes.
I can definitely relate to that.
I would say take time to enjoy
the little things in life,
like for me, I try to romanticize school,
I'll sit somewhere nice
with a pretty view,
read a book, I'll get
myself a cup of coffee,
just the little things that add up.
It just makes my day a little better.
Doesn't make me feel like
I'm forced to be here
and I don't feel like
I'm just a student here
with another red ID or something.
- Okay, it says I have absolutely
no idea what I'm doing.
Honestly, I completely relate to this.
This is my first year here in grad school
as a literature major because
I wanna be a professor.
Still don't know if I wanna do that.
I feel like there's a lot of expectations
from my family being Asian
and a professor's not really a thing
that people look up to
in my culture I guess.
Yeah, I can relate to that
and all I can say is
it eventually works out
and I know it's gonna work out for me too
but I'm just here along for the ride,
I don't really know what's gonna happen.
But you're not alone, yeah.
- I've never been on a date,
I've never been in a relationship before,
I've never held hands with someone
and I've never received flowers.
I feel so unlovable.
I wish there were other ways
for them to look at options, you know?
To feel like oh, you hold
hands with family, you know,
a little kid, a nephew
or anything like that
'cause those people,
if you've got a nephew
or a young child or a niece, I
shouldn't be gender specific,
you know, someone young that
wants to hold your hand,
they can love you unconditionally.
I'll be honest and this
isn't a secret that,
this wasn't gonna be
something that I write,
I've only been on one
or two dates with people
and I don't have an extremely high amount
of romantic relationships
with a lot of people.
And so I face some of
these similar challenges
of being like how do I find myself
and view myself as
someone who can be loved
in a romantic way or anything like that?
There's a lot of ways to experience
and spread love and the more
that you are willing to
open yourself up to it,
there's gonna be opportunities
for it to find you
and for you to interact and
enjoy that feeling, you know?
- It says I had intense sexual trauma
after my relationship with my ex.
It's been over a year since I left him now
and I've finally recovered.
I'm extremely proud of myself for that.
It was one of the most difficult things
to go through but I made it.
Yesterday was my birthday
and late at night
I got sad thinking about him
and missing our relationship.
I feel ashamed that he was
the last person I thought of.
He hurt me so bad and shouldn't deserve
my thoughts of affection.
I thought I was past this state
and me missing him feels like a betrayal
towards the younger version of me.
She was completely destroyed and I swore
to never betray myself like that again.
Yeah.
I feel like healing
from trauma isn't linear
and you can never really expect yourself
to be past a certain point.
That's something I have
to remind myself of too
and it's not easy.
Yeah, healing doesn't
happen in a straight line
and sometimes you feel like you backtrack
but it's all part of the process
and some days are easier than others
so you just kind of have to
let the emotions come and go
naturally but also, I
mean whoever that was,
I'm so proud of you for
making the effort to heal
and for going through that and yeah,
bearing with it for however long it takes.
After writing mine,
I feel good.
I, mine was pretty light hearted
and I like that I got to participate
so I feel good. (laughing)
- All right, that's it
for today's episode,
thank you for watching, I love you all
and I'll see you next week.